Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit about
a critical race theory.
Protest gone completely haywire in Ashburn,
Virginia.
The school board of this wealthy county, Loudoun
County in Virginia, wanted to hold a meeting
to close out the school year.
And it became complete and total chaos in
this Washington, D.C. suburb as parents who
apparently are against critical race theory,
although it's not completely clear they really
know what it is they wanted to protest critical
race theory.
We're going to look at some video clips here.
This is wild, wild stuff.
Here is one parent, the founder of Parents
Against Critical Race Theory, speaking to
a crowd outside the event.
Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Do you think you're doing is changing
the race theory?
Is
the framework actually responsive to you?
It's all.
Trojan horses and equity and diversity and
inclusion, you know, come on, you know.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Who would want any of that stuff, guys?
I mean, that's just crazy.
It's crazy what they're trying to teach.
Now, I am a critic of critical race theory
this week.
One of the things that happens in academia
is you have a theory and then you have critiques
of the theory.
And that's all normal and good.
But we don't we don't want to teach inclusion.
We don't want to teach the value of equality.
I mean, it's he doesn't even really seem to
understand what critical race theory is.
Then, of course, they broke into the national
anthem.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Early we started to
Speaker 1: see I think you get the impression
this is not it's it's they're just standing
in the parking lot singing the national anthem.
Again, if you were to satire, sort of like
ignorant, clueless protests of critical race
theory, this is what they would look like.
Then the crowd inside the event wouldn't shut
up and they had to threaten to end the meeting.
Speaker 2: Disgusting rhetoric.
Speaker 1: So there were threats that if these
people don't quiet down, they're going to
have to attend the meeting and then they did
actually and the public comment section and
people went completely nuts.
Oh, my goodness.
So that was after the announcement that they
were going to have to wrap the thing up because
people were going completely crazy and things
just continued getting wilder and wilder.
Take a look.
Oh, this is when they go back into the national
anthem.
The meeting was ended and they go back into
the national anthem.
Unidentified: Dear God, guys, you guys.
Speaker 1: So that went on.
And then then the arrests started happening.
Here is you will this is while an arrest is
going on.
I think in this clip you hear someone yell
who pays your salary to the police officers
as well.
Unidentified: There it is.
Speaker 1: OK, so people getting completely
outraged, I guess they're mad at everything,
getting mad at the police, getting mad at
the school board, getting mad at the tea,
everybody's furious with everybody.
And then this is sort of like the cherry on
top.
Here is a guy getting getting himself arrested
in the midst of this police force.
Now, by the way, you know, we talk about resisting
arrest is used as a catchall when police want
to manhandle someone by the standards we normally
see applied to what counts as resisting arrest.
This guy is doing it and police treating him
very, very politely.
As you can tell,
Unidentified: you guys don't read this stuff.
Right.
So listen, listen, listen to me
Speaker 2: at this point, because it's not
over.
Speaker 1: I love how the guy says.
The officer says the meeting is over and the
guy says it's not.
You can see if you're watching the video that
there's almost no one left.
So the meeting clearly is over.
I think that's more of an empirical question.
The meeting has ended, but just another complete
and total humiliation.
And this is sort of a mind virus.
This is an example of where the idea of critical
race theory as an indoctrination strategy
in high schools has spread like a virus among
some of these right wingers.
And they can no longer think sensibly.
They can no longer behave like adults.
It's a real sad thing to see, but they seem
to have really latched on to this in a pretty
serious way.
I don't expect this to go away any time soon.
And we may do even a deep dove on critical
race theory at some point in the next few
weeks, because it is becoming I mean, listen,
these are adults supposedly and look at what
the idea, the misunderstood idea that they
have of critical race theory has done to them.
I'm all for serious critiques of critical
race theory.
I've done them.
I think it's reductive.
And I think it's not the type of theory that
will further race relations.
But I'm not going to be showing up and getting
myself arrested and screaming.
I'm just glad to talk to people about it in
a calm, sensible and rational way.
I don't expect this to end any time soon.
We'll have some more of these clips on the
show's Instagram, which you can find at David
Pakman show.
You can also find me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be right back